PART.
IF IT GOT TO COURT.
>> PAMELA BROWN WITH THE
REPORTING.
THANK YOU.
>>> DAVID ARENBERG IS JOINING
US.
A STATE ATTORNEY FOR PALM BEACH
COUNTY AND ELLIE WILLIAMS IS A
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AND
CNN ANALYST.
ELLIOT, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
INVOKING HIS FIFTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS HERE.
IT HAS GONE ON FOR HOUR SIX.
WE HEARD.
IS THERE WHAT YOU EXPECTED THAT
HE WOULD DO, KNOWING HIS HISTORY
OF THE DEPOSITIONS?
>> YEAH, I THINK SO.
SO IT'S A FEW THINGS, VICTOR.
WHAT THE FIFTH AMENDMENT IS.
IT SAYS IN THE CONSTITUTION NO
PERSON CAN BE COMPELLED TO
TESTIFY AGAINST THEMSELVES.
YOU CAN'T BRING SOMEONE IN TO
HAVE THEM TESTIFY AND USE THE
TESTIMONY IN A CRIMINAL
PROCEEDING.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENCE, IF DO YOU HAVE WATCHED
A COP SHOW, THAT'S THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT
ASSERTED HERE.
YOU KNOW, ACTUALLY, HE'S GOT A
BASIS FOR ASSERTING THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT HERE, BECAUSE WE KNOW
ABOUT AN ONGOING CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION IN NEW YORK CITY
BASED ON THE SAME FACTS THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING TODAY.
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER HE
UNLAWFULLY INFLATED THE VALUES
OF SOME OF HIS PROPERTIES.
SO, YOU KNOW, YES, WE COULD HAVE
EXPECTED IT.
IT MIGHT BE THE ONE TIME DONALD
TRUMP ACTUALLY HAS A FIFTH
AMENDMENT CLAIM TO BRING.
>> DAVE, THIS IS A FINANCIAL
INVESTIGATION, RIGHT?
THEY'RE TRYING TO DETERMINE IF
HE I BELIEVE FLATED OR DEFLATED
THE VALUES OF PROPERTIES,
THEREFORE, INSURERS OR BUSINESS
CONTACTS.
THESE CASES ARE MADE ON PAPER.
HOW DETRIMENTAL, MAYBE, IS THIS
TO THE CASE, OR NOT?
>> IT'S HARD TO TELL.
BECAUSE WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
ECONOMIC CASES, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
LIE.
A PAPER DOESN'T.
THAT'S WHY YOU WANT TO FIND THE
PAPER TRAIL.
BUT TRUMP DOESN'T USE E-MAIL OR
TEXT MESSAGES.
THAT'S WHY THEY WANTED HIM TO
TESTIFY.
NOW THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET IT.
BECAUSE IT'S A CIVIL
INVESTIGATION, DONALD TRUMP'S
TAKING OF THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
CAN BE USED AGAINST HIM ADDS A
NEGATIVE INFERENCE AT CIVIL
TRIAL.
SO TRUMP WAS CAUGHT IN A BOX
HERE.
IF HE TOOK THE FIFTH, THEN HE
AVOIDS HAVING HIS STATEMENTS
USED AGAINST HIM IN A CRIMINAL
TRIAL.
THERE IS A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, AS ELLIOT POINTED
OUT, BUT AT THE SAME TIME, HE
RISKS HAVING THE IMPLICATION OF
THE FIFTH, CREATING A NEGATIVE
INFERENCE AGAINST HIM IN A CIVIL
TRIAL.
SOLY TISSUESHA JAMES WILL USE
THAT AGAINST HIM.
IF YOU DON'T I HAVE A CIVIL
INVESTIGATION MATTERS, ASK
IVANKA.
THE TRUMP FOUNDATION WAS SHUT
DOWN BECAUSE OF ACTION TAKEN BY
ATTORNEY GENERAL JAMES.
THE SAME PERSON IN CHARGE OF
THIS.
>> NOW, DAVID, YOU SAID IT COULD
BE USED AS A NEGATIVE INFERENCE
IN A CIVIL TRIAL.
DO YOU EXPECT IT'LL GO THAT FAR
TO A TRIAL?
>> THESE THINGS RARELY GO TO
TRIAL.
THEY USUALLY SETTLE.
JUST LIKE THE DONALD TRUMP
FOUNDATION.
THEY AGREED TO DISBAND THE
I EXPECT THIS TO SETTLE.
I EXPECT THAT THERE WILL BE AN
ACTION BROUGHT AGAINST TRUMP AND
THE ORGANIZATION BY JAMES.
SHE'S COME A LONG WAY TO GET THE
DEPOSITION.
I THINK SHE'LL KEEP PURSUING IT
TO THE END.
THE BIGGER QUESTION WHETHER IT
LEADS TO CRIMINAL CHARGES.
MY COUNTER PART HAS PUT THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION ON HOLD.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CONTROVERSY
ABOUT THAT.
TRUMP WAS WORRIED IF HE SAID THE
WRONG THING, IT COULD REIGNITE
THAT CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
I THINK HE DOESN'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THAT AS MUCH AS CIVIL
CHARGES COMING.
>> YEAH.
ELLIOT, WHAT DO YOU MAKE ABOUT
THE DISPARITY IN STRATEGY HERE?
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS INVOKING THE FIFTH.
ALSO, HIS SON ERIC TRUMP INVOKED
THE FIFTH.
SO HAS ALAN WISE L BERG.
DONALD TRUMP JR., IVANKA TRUMP
ANSWERED QUESTIONS.
ERIC TRUMP AND DONALD TRUMP JR.
ARE LEADING THIS ORGANIZATION,
OR AT LEAST THEY WERE DURING THE
ADMINISTRATION, TAKING DIFFERENT
ROADS.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING HERE?
>> YOU KNOW, LOOK, THERE'S A
QUESTION AS TO WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT IS PLAYING FOUR
DIMENSIONAL CHESS WHILE EVERYONE
AROUND HIM IS PLAYING CHECKERS
AND THERE'S A GRAND STRATEGY
HERE.
I'M NOT CONVINCED THEY HAVE A
BROADER GRAND STRATEGY HERE.
IT LOOKS SPLASHY TO PLEAD THE
FIFTH.
IT'S PROBABLY AS MUCH A
POLITICAL AND PUBLIC RELATIONS
STRATEGY AS A LEGAL ONE.
NOTWITHSTANDING THE LEGAL POINTS
WE HAVE MADE HERE.
I THINK THERE'S A LITTLE MORE
BEHIND THIS THAN STRATEGY.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE
SEARCH WARRANT THAT WAS EXECUTED
ON MONDAY AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THERE IS THE RETURN.
THERE'S THE INVENTORY OF
EVERYTHING THAT WAS TAKEN.
IF THIS IS SO EGREGIOUS, AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID IT WAS, SHOULD
THE FORMER PRESIDENT MAKE THAT
PUBLIC?
>> OH, YES.
HE CAN.
HE CAN RELEASE THE SEARCH
WARRANT.
HE CAN RELEASE THE INVENTORY.
HE WON'T DO SO BECAUSE HE KNOWS
THAT'LL UNDERMINE HIS CLAIM HE
DID NOTHING WRONG.
I THINK THE CLAIM THAT THE DOJ
SHOULD BE THE ONE THAT IS
TRANSPARENT.
YOU SAW WHAT MITCH McCONNELL
SAID.
TALK ABOUT IT, MERRICK GARLAND.
HE KNOW PROSECUTORS LIVE BY A
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES THAN
POLITICIANS.
WE CANNOT PROVIDE DETAILS ABOUT
A PENDING INVESTIGATION THAT CAN
JEOPARDIZE OUR SOURCES AND OUR
CASE.
YOU'RE DEPRIVING A FUTURE
DEFENDANT OF A RIGHT TO A FAIR
TRIAL, IF YOU LITIGATE IT IN THE
PRESS.
BUT THE POTENTIAL SUSPECT HERE,
DONALD TRUMP, IT'S NOT SUBJECT
TO THE SAME RULES.
HE CAN RELEASE ALL THAT ST